[Music]
one comic is better than the other
people think it's them we're smoking and
joking and having a blast two Comics two
cigars two Comics two cigars
yeah what's going on everybody it's
Robert Kelly and
I'm here with the great Aaron Berg
and we are here doing two Comics two
cigars live at at skank Fest
do I say live no it's not live
from skank Fest live from skank Fest we
got a great cigar for you guys today I'm
very excited about this one
is a friend of ours do you want to
introduce the cigar it is the my father
Libby Zhu 1922. 1922. look at that and
my father is known for their amazing
bands I mean the best bands in the
business yeah great bands they
look like they make the cigars way more
expensive than they are yes these are
decently priced cigars to say the least
so I mean shockingly yeah because I I
remember the first time I went to buy a
box for Joe's wedding
and it was I don't know
under 200 for a box which is nuts and
two about two boxes two different cigars
and two of my favorite cigars what was
the other one
um it was one was the um
it's the sea the um
has The Big C on it yes I know it but I
can't think of the name of it right now
right here the name will come up yep the
the what the hell is it it's a a CR uh
[ __ ] has the orange seed yeah it's not I
I can't remember for the life of me
right just cut right here look it up
on your phone I think it's called um
a crap what the [ __ ] is it
I hate all right I don't want to swear
anymore I'm gonna stop swearing why I
swear too much
I swear too much anyways it was did you
get it I'm fine my father
gotta find all these
there we go here's the brand Brands my
father think of the name kryon
too futuristic you want to say Camacho
but it's not Camacho's a different brand
sit it's not Dom Pepin it's Al Centurion
Centurion there it is right there
Centurion is my yeah I mean what a great
cigar and there's the other one I got
the other one Fleur de las and tilas oh
boy they were good dude those are good
these guys don't mess around with their
cigars they don't mess around and here's
the thing with these cigars they start
out spicy yeah they start out spicy then
they mellow the [ __ ] out to the end of
the cigar it it is a tongue Grabber yeah
you you know it's I mean it it makes you
a tongue grab I just made that up I know
no one else has ever said that a tongue
it's impossible to grab someone by the
Tongue pretty much this is two Comics
two cigars where any two Comics not just
me not just Ari anybody you get another
comic and all you have to do is smoke
the same cigar yeah you talk about it at
the beginning the middle at the end and
then we rate it at the end you could
franchise this show out it could be
other Comics you could make it an
international show where people in
England could do it yeah as long as
you're a comic and it's not like
headliners
it's not academics yeah as you can see
now it's not a Headliners you can be a
headliner and you can be a Midler I'm
not a meddler I don't even say that
don't make these people feature the only
feature I apologize who would follow me
if I featured nobody you're a [ __ ]
murderer Bobby went with what type of
cut I went with the you know what this
is why I'm so excited to do this with
you yeah because you're a cigar guy yeah
you know sometimes you do this they
don't know what the hell's going on I
went with the punch Do you inhale this I
know they ask you that how do you smoke
it if you don't inhale because I want to
inhale it you know why you want to do
that because you're an idiot you gotta
know I can't do that because I was an
idiot when I never wanted to inhalers no
I didn't I'm not that much of an idiot
but when I first started smoking cigars
I what happens with cigars the reason
why a lot of guys don't mess with them
it's you know how do you cut it how do
you light it how do you smoke it can I
put it out
it does none of that [ __ ] matters
there's a lot of questions a lot of
questions it's not easy to be a good
cigar smoker by the way it's not easy I
I disagree really I because you know
what I've learned get a cigar that you
like smoke it light it whatever you want
to light it and when you're done put it
out you don't have to smoke the whole
thing you want to smoke it down to a nub
go ahead all right I think that you just
you know smoke a [ __ ] cigar okay
smoke it I don't mind that I went with a
straight cut I went with the uh punch
the punch now you get a it's a heavier
draw okay because the tobacco's coming
through that little hole the that cut
it's it's more of a clean draw I like
that you know what I mean I've always
been a straight cut guy unless I forget
my Straight cutter at home then in the
car I got a v cutter and then I got to
use that and your sex life you're not
straight that's true
definitely a whole you're a whole you're
a hole punch in that whole punch what
bottom hole puncher now you're gonna let
your cigar with a i rot I I don't travel
with the torch yeah so I travel with one
of these it's illegal to travel with a
torch illegal but it's fine to steal an
election
is he going
I would like to actually use your torch
if you may if you don't now Bobby said
you can of course light a cigar with a
Bic lighter yeah it's fine it's not
windy here but when I'm on the road and
I'm gonna have a stick and I've just got
a crappy little lighter I'm furious to
me the torch is part of the pleasure of
starting the cigar up holding it up
heating it a little bit Bobby's already
done this on previous shows taught you
how to light a cigar and then that first
puff is just much better than trying to
like suck start a lawnmower with this
little torch well
by the way here's the difference between
uh Bobby and I Bobby although an
ex-addict uh
can wait to smoke and he said today he
goes let's do this thing at one o'clock
and I was up so early and I go man I'd
like to smoke before we smoke that's
what I was thinking I got I got I'm here
I got you all right all right
all right here we go I got the toys let
me ask you this can I do it I don't fly
with the torch do not fly with a good
lighter because they will snap they take
it they do make a torch uh regular Flame
okay
so when you push it it looks like a Bic
yeah but underneath
you can click another button and it
becomes a torch so
uh it's so they have cheap ones they're
very Dupont very expensive ones and so
it's both
um so you can light a pipe and you can
light a cigar yeah it's football you
still smoking pipes yeah once in a while
yeah but you can do it but I anytime I
go to town I go to I go to a store a
tobacco store I buy a three-door this
one all right yeah I don't mind those I
don't know what this is we gotta find
out why they we have to ask that why do
they leave because some people think do
I light my stick up with this little
orange thing this piece of felt I bet if
we asked Steve or Moe they would tell us
why that was let's see the uh ring on
the end of the cigar is it yeah you know
what it is I Know What It Is What It
protects the end of the cigar okay I
guarantee that's what it is toasting the
cigars we've taught you I'm not even
talking to the microphone yeah toasting
the cigar toast things
oh
you know what oh man
and when you toast it that means that
that first draw that you get is gonna be
pure cigar yeah got a whole bunch of gas
and garbage yeah not a bunch of gas now
this cigar I mean out of the gate
this is rocking and rolling
this is great this is a tongue Grabber
now the the might be you by the way
comes in different sizes my favorite of
which is the petite robusto which I
found was a great daily cigar really
small
they were sold out Across America you
couldn't get you couldn't get them for
six to eight months really
I mean it's a clean cigar you know the
judge is another good cigar from my
father if you ever looking at my if
you're ever anywhere my father's in
pretty much every cigar place around
you'll find them my father
they they were able to break into the
industry this is [ __ ] what happened you
handed me the light up from the top and
you grabbed the hot part I wasn't
looking who does that
you burnt my thumb my thumb's a little
burnt too I think it was the lighter's
fault wow
my father broke into the cigar industry
started making these Boutique type
cigars at a good price point and they
compete with the best cigars like the
highest priced cigars in the world
Boutique cigars my favorite the smaller
company I love the big names Cohiba
you know
um hoyo Monte Cristo those are the big
big daddies but the tatawaje
um Caldwell my father
uh Roma craft
I mean they've been out there for a
while yeah but these are the foundation
Foundation Jesus long live the king who
makes those Caldwell yeah I believe I'm
saying that right yeah my my favorite
thing one of my favorites of guys yeah
long live the king six by sixty
it's a big stick dude it's a perfect
size stick I think
I love it it's one of it's hard it's
hard to get
it's a very small boutique company the
guys I follow them on Instagram it's
kind of crazy a little crazy is he a
little bit I like it though good crazy
crazy how he just does his own that hey
this came out today [ __ ] uh yeah
there's a shirt that said he sucks
really yeah he's kind of fun you know oh
anyways we're here with you and you
you're um you've been all over the place
first of all what are you talking about
you
everything I turn on you on because you
got a special out now Guild box yeah and
uh you've been promoting it like crazy
go Box available right now Louis ck.com
it's a good website to sell stuff on you
gotta direct it too you know I'm very
I'm I'm uh totally humbled and grateful
that he
produced it directed it
uh everything put it on his website and
the community comedy community
every you everybody's gotten behind me
which I love I haven't put a special out
in five years not because I didn't want
to
uh I really wanted to but nobody would
give me that shot nobody you know
Netflix we love Robert Kelly but you've
done stuff with Netflix before you were
on this they gave me generous they gave
me they'll give you a 20 minute thing
but they can't give me a H whatever I
mean I don't I don't have a fight that
[ __ ] yeah because it's not a battle to
be won and it's not a bridge to be
burned because you never know when you
do something else with them you know
what I mean so it's like whatever your
reason is if you here's my rule you
don't want me I don't want you
why the why would I want to be with
somebody that doesn't want me yeah so
there you go but technology has advanced
so much in the last 10 years that now
everybody's just doing their specials by
themselves at the the vu
uh which is great but I didn't want to
do I've already done that I did that my
last question was at the Village
something different than what everybody
was special yeah I want we could have
done it
you know there's talented guys that if
uh that are uh filming these things
really they're great but I wanted
something special I wanted I told Louie
I go dude I don't care if you're looking
through an iPhone as long as you're
looking through the lens and directing
it
and but I I would like to do something
special I'm I wanted we talked about it
we wanted to create a space we wanted to
create a little kill box we wanted to
create a holy [ __ ] Comedy Club
and we wanted it to be like the Elvis's
68 special yeah his Comeback Special
yeah and if you if you saw that movie
yeah I saw that movie twice it was great
I mean he was like he didn't listen to
anybody yep he went he went he went rock
and roll he didn't listen to his dumb
manager and all the people and the
corporation he said screw them it's very
similar you know there's some some
Parables I said yeah you're Elvis
um I was chubby Elvis in this one
there's a lot of Parables still singing
like a [ __ ] over that piano
though but his face and I blame that
colonel
I blame I blame the colonel for that yes
he did it I fully blame it Elvis could
have gone International could have kept
going and going that colonel was a
[ __ ] dick wow the colonel and his
people around him too they ball had this
dad turned on him they're feeding him
drugs
that one moment where he goes whatever
you got to do to get him out on that
stage and they pull a syringe out yeah
Elvis was amazing yes now you captured
this in killbox for how long how long
does it set an hour 20. we captured this
you kill first of all you kill wherever
you go
you I don't know how many years you've
been doing it for You're a murderer
I do but
it's funny
yeah I mean it's just my style
you know like Boston is you go and you
go and you go and you yeah you don't let
them up yeah and so and and
you know
yeah I I don't know I just I [ __ ]
that's my thing that's I don't like I
like to grab them by the neck and let go
when I'm done that's what I do too yeah
there's other styles of comedy and I
have respect for it but that's what I
like doing it's just Rattle and rattle
it and then you realize at some points
you're killing so hard you could slow
down and let the laughs roll but it just
feels wrong it feels wrong it feels
wrong when people are like oh you don't
even give us time to catch up and I'm
like yeah but I don't need to like
that's part of the magic of that thing
yeah that's part of what it you could
slow down I could slow down and for a
while it's tempting to when you try when
you do a late night set you slow down a
little bit
I like I like to slow down I like even
while I did The Tonight Show I was bing
bing bing bing I tried to I mean tried
to bring a club set to late night I did
it that way I didn't do the setup punch
tag tag and then smile of the audience I
was like
you know I had a quarter I had a corded
mic first time in 16 years that's nice I
was like I haven't done this in 16 years
they had to plug me into the roots
because they do wireless yeah or no mic
it's awful yeah no mic you're holding
the mic for no reason it's weird I feel
like I'm doing a [ __ ] one-man show
when that happens yeah that's what they
wanted to look Elvis I want to go back
to Elvis yeah first of all this is your
him we're gonna talk about this cigar at
the beginning it opens up beautifully
it's strong it's not overwhelming
I got uh I got how hacky would it be to
say peppery it's peppery it's it's a
tongue Grabber right out of the game
that's a new way of saying peppery look
at it look at the burn on it yeah it's
they make really good cigars my father
does not [ __ ] around no look at that oil
I mean look at that that wrap that rap
is like just
you know it's like the perfect black
penis
right
Sorry by the way there's Donuts inside I
had one when's the last time you had a
donut
um
Jesus
six months really yeah why
it was really tasty and I and I hate how
I feel after I eat a donut but I had
that donut and I was like oh my God that
was good dude I don't I don't mess with
sugar no more no more sugar no more
sugar fruits
yeah sure I I I yeah I blow guys once in
a while yeah
no I have fruit yeah of course I have
fruit fruit nuts processed sugar no no
no no what about dark chocolate what do
you do for when you're craving sweets I
can have a dark chocolate I have
fudgicles no sugar fragos fudgicles no
sugar popsicles no sugar pudding yeah
yeah I can have all that no sugar stuff
all the chemicals that are going to give
me cancer yeah I can have that you can
have those that's fine yeah this is all
all you've been talking about I'm
guessing for the last month it's been
the special and you're you're weight
loss well yeah I got the surgery yeah
yeah it was uh it was it's been a pretty
holy holy cow yeah uh six months you
feel better now I feel
I I can't tell you how much better I
feel tell me I know heartburn no no
breathing heavy blood pressure down no
tingly feet at night
um no swelling
um I can walk I can do whatever I want
now
I mean I I I feel my energy levels are
through the roof I can go I can wake up
at seven and go all night until it sleep
beautifully when you wake up you jump
right out of bed now he's gone wake up
out of bed oh wow I mean everything in
my life is turned around completely
because I got that surgery now I don't
here's the thing I don't suggest if
everybody because I had you I had to do
a lot of work I had to go to a doctor
nutritionist I had to go to a heart guy
I had to get all this work up done I
think six months
it was a lot of work and then lose
weight I had to lose I'd get my BMI down
how'd you do that I walked and I ate
less crap oh yeah now I could have done
that I know why don't you just do that
before no one's saying that no but I in
my head they do well do they I was doing
I always do in my head people yeah I do
what the [ __ ] dude you're not funny
yeah what the [ __ ] I got kill box it was
all right yeah
should have called me [ __ ] her hurt
box you didn't kill me yeah Hurt Locker
yeah maybe uh ouch box
the people in your head are very stupid
I don't think
I don't think that they're concerned
about goddamn right they are yeah
um but you did it again you're down a
lot what are you down now I don't know I
gotta weigh myself next week you only
weigh yourself on a schedule I know
that's nice that's good I weighed myself
and I was down like 70. you're you're
forehead and Cranium looks leaner like
up here this upper part of your head
yeah look at this this shirt I'm wearing
by the way look how wide your head is on
the top and now it's starting to get
like lean I had silverback gorilla head
yeah it's funny we I didn't you have fat
on your head yeah is that nuts like the
top of my head was fat I FaceTime my
wife I don't be laying down I'm like oh
[ __ ] what's this yeah it's terrible yeah
but yeah dude it was amazing
amazing so now I you have to start
weighing myself now because
you know I could eat something that
isn't good and I you know you know I
want to know where I'm at so I'll start
weighing myself now but I I mean I'm
done this is a life thing yeah it's the
way I am now so if I I weigh myself it's
like for what
I I feel good right now yeah you're
gonna change it's gonna go I get to go
to the gym now it's fun right see me in
there this morning yeah yo you you do
you're a different person though what do
you mean
I'm doing you know 20 pound dumbbells
you're working out we're still working
out you were doing some other [ __ ]
though I just go on your knees that
wasn't blowing a guy I don't know what
that was dude I was doing abs I was
doing midsection but I'm not I'm not
imperfect I'm not in perfect shape I
feel okay but I'm still I gotta I gotta
lose 20 30 pounds yeah oh yeah I'm most
people either 20 or 30. wow I Gotta Lose
I probably Gotta Lose another 70. well
you will
but anyways yeah so I feel good specials
out talking about that uh doing a bunch
more this week
a bunch of the big ones coming up you do
appearances on all these podcasts now
and you were the guy that started the
comic podcast thing in New York there's
no look Maron was around he was doing
his [ __ ] but you were you were the
prototypical New York podcast guy yeah
and everybody that came up through your
show or on your show has Brandon
branched out you guys like I saw on
Schultz's show the other day it's like a
[ __ ] TV studio over there it's insane
Schultz is taking it to a Next Level
yeah I mean him and his crew all those
guys
I mean it's like doing a TV show I mean
it really is yeah there's a whole floor
of a building in SoHo they all come up
in the elevator with like electric
motorcycles yeah it's like the future
and then they bring you through this
thing it's you come out like uh doing
The Tonight Show yeah and you come on
it's unbelievable and I mean but he he's
I mean that guy's helped me out so much
too really he's not I love him because
he's not greedy with the success he
wants people to take this take it yeah
this is what I did do this don't do that
let me help you yeah call me up on my
special put me online with the people
doing your videos I want to text red
with all of us and he was like change
that do this really make this hat yes
it's great he knows he's great he knows
it all he figured it out and he gives it
away a lot some people it's not easy
though you still gotta put the work in
some people covet yeah you know what I
mean he doesn't covet
and it and it's weird to see the
difference in your Instagram when you
change I gotta listen to him I gotta
call him again he's the best because I
left you know I had I was at another
Network for a while and I left there the
network that will be unnamed which is
Harry Potter Dumbledore yeah what no uh
I worked at compound media for a long
time yeah a long time so I left and then
you know there was a bump where a lot of
my fans didn't come with me really so it
was like I had to
um I had to like recreate and Rebrand
and go out and build a whole new fan
base so I reached out to Schultz and
he's like here's what you got to do do
this and this and I was like dude this
is still a lot of work it's not even
it's not a magic formula where you go oh
this is what Schultz did I just got to
change it you still got to put a lot of
work in and there's this thing you've
been doing this for so long where
there's two different beasts there's
there's the actual stand-up of it and
you could be so [ __ ] phenomenal yeah
and not hit that tear of fame or well
yeah and then there's that other part
that's the business part of it and you
know Schultz just happens to be really
good at both parts of it he's good at
both parts but he's also got that it
let me tell you something Schultz is is
smart
and man you make smarts with confidence
and funny
that's pretty wild yeah and I remember
he was on my podcast one time
and um we're back we had a little
technical difficulty plus the Nevada son
was beating on our bald heads and we
didn't want to get uh you know skin
cancer
and throat cancer at the same time wow
it was uh very hot so we moved back
about a foot and a half an hour in the
shade yeah we were talking about before
Andrew and was the best yep but we can't
recreate the conversation no I'm just
gonna move on we're talking about me
going to the hospital yes I want to know
because here's the thing I was in
Chicago with you yeah and we had a good
time we spoke so guys we talked you
under a lot of pressure
no need to get into that but we're
getting a lot of pressure
I get home
my wife's got people from the
neighborhood over she goes the kids are
here to play oh when I get home after a
long trip you kind of want to decompress
for a little bit yep I go I'm real tired
let me lay down she's like people are
here we gotta I'm like all right I jump
right back into it I go out I get pizza
for everybody my head's pounding for
some reason I don't know what it is I go
maybe I need caffeine this is what a
dummy I am I drink more uh I drink more
caffeine I go out I smoke a bit of a
stick while I'm driving to get the pizza
why do you have a headache no idea and
then I start getting real itchy my skin
is itchy I don't know what's going on we
figured maybe I ate sesame seeds I'm
allergic to Sesame seeds yeah it's
really good oh my God such a gay Jew
reality dude Sesame Sesame seeds this is
a kid at school that ruins everything
yeah oh everything yeah sesame seeds are
the best I love sesame sure oh
everything Bagels
Sushi Big Macs yep no Big Macs you're
not bringing Big Macs to my school wow
you just go with the bun with no sesame
seeds on it
Shake Shack makes Better Burgers than a
Big Mac dude I don't want this to turn
into Joe DeRosa himself welcome
thank you
I love that show though they get so
angry I went on it it's a pancake the
hash browns are better than Denny's the
eggs are part of the breakfast
they yell this is big enough you I did
it with Sal yeah you get so heated he
said a sloppy joe is better than a
turkey club he's insane he's nuts yeah
he's nuts he's [ __ ] see I'm getting
heavy and you argue about it yeah they
get so upset I love it it's a very fun
show I'm allergic people Comics argue
about the Ukraine yeah yeah and I'd
rather have them argue about [ __ ]
sloppy you want to see Sal vulcano go up
against Dave Smith one of them argues
Politics the other one just orders junk
food so you were dying I I didn't know
that I'm itchy my wife goes take a
Claritin I take that I go I'm still
itchy wives don't give a [ __ ] they just
want you to keep that [ __ ] keep it
moving yeah I I can keep it moving
because they get sick they just keep
going wives my wife goes to [ __ ] body
pain yeah I still have a cold for six
weeks just drinking soon my wife had
sepsis for a month yeah just walk
through it my wife had scurvy just kept
going to work teaching kids she got HIV
yeah
and [ __ ] kept going wives do what
we're little [ __ ] when we get sick
we're like I can't I can't no I gotta
stay home oh I want my back rubbed if I
throw up if you don't come in we got
into a big fight because I was puking
and she's like I'm like you're a [ __ ]
she's like why because my grandmother
would rub my back and see if I'm all
right I said that too my mom used to put
rubbing alcohol on my back my wife goes
I'm not your mother I'm not going to
coddle you like that well then you
should have told me that before yes but
she wouldn't have that's why they
pretend to get along with your mother
the whole time so that they think that
they're going to be the next mother
unbelievable then I take a Benadryl she
goes take a Benadryl that's the thing
take this take that yeah so Benadryl
usually knocks you out so all of a
sudden I'm like I can't I don't know
what's going on she goes let's take your
blood pressure so we got the machine
take it it's high I go it's a little
high let me let me meditate for a minute
like that's gonna help
I do
I'm still open your mouth thinking about
birds
take it again it's higher it's high she
goes she goes we're doing something I go
I don't know you want me to go to the I
go I'm not calling the Amy that's too
much money she goes nah I go go to the
clinic and she goes it's not going to be
open it's calls 9-1-1 they show up oh
what's going on and I'm laying there
daughter's asleep they they take the
pressure they're like you're you're in
stroke area right now he's like I gotta
I gotta call an ambulance I'm sure
you're in such great shape it's what you
would think the stress [ __ ] jacked me
up I don't think I was eating and I'll
tell you this I didn't consciously I did
not eat [ __ ] and you know Chicago is a
town where you can eat real [ __ ] dog
[ __ ] I didn't they take a roast beef sub
and dip it in the sauce yeah that's
exactly what people just eat a wet sauce
yeah and I didn't I didn't go for a
steak I had two slices of deep dish
that's it I was good you know I I smoked
a couple sticks and then I he goes
you're real high then the ambulance
comes the cops first the cops showed up
by the way and then uh and then they
take me in the ambulance why the [ __ ] do
they gotta show up I don't know how does
everybody because anytime you make a
call they think someone's punching the
[ __ ] out of their wife that's the big
thing my blood pressure's high from what
punching the [ __ ] out of my wife that's
not a good thing how good a relationship
is by the fridge the dents in the fridge
yeah if you back her up and it goes
right around her head
you got it I've never hit my wife but
I've hit a lot of you know as soon as a
cop comes into your house you're like oh
this guy thinks I'm beating the [ __ ] out
of my wife oh yeah that's that's what I
think there's a copying a gay man yeah a
gay man yeah in the 20s I live with a
roommate once they came over they
thought we were fighting because we were
we were lovers
they were like you guys okay well like
what do you mean we've got a big fight
we're gonna I was gonna kick the [ __ ]
out of him yeah and then like you guys
having a fight I'm like yeah we're
having a fight he's a guy nobody you
know can you work this out between you
guys and I'm like what are you talking
about you guys you guys are together I'm
not you think he's 350. this was sexy
Bobby too yeah you think I'm [ __ ]
that yeah look at me where was this in
Hell's Kitchen no this is in Boston yeah
anyways
go I get in that thing they take me then
they do it again they go oh you're like
you're 200 over 140. you could stroke
out so they take me to the hospital they
give me this thing it dissolves in my
mouth they do all my level and I tell
Christine I go go go home go I'll be
fine and she's like no so we she has to
go wake up the neighbors she goes I
gotta go to the hospital with Aaron we
have these lovely Republican older
people neighbors they're like hippies
that became Republicans oh you gotta
love a republican neighbor I love a
republican they will not let anybody go
to your house they're the best they'll
call you if anything goes wrong
Republican neighbors [ __ ] rule oh my
God I have a guy next to me my neighbor
he's a a cop yeah he's got yeah he's got
a he's just awesome him this girl he's
got a cop flag a trump flag an American
flag best neighbor best neighbor you
can't get a better neighbor no you
imagine one of these liberal people
living next to you I gotta I go the
other side I do the purple house but
they're good too yeah they're good for
other things yeah like they're very can
you water my lawn I don't believe in
using excess water they get the mail
yeah they get them that's nice they're
very nice yeah my Republican neighbors
are good the other side is uh they're
pretty my whole neighborhood's pretty
Republican I live in a pretty good
neighborhood uh anyways we get I'm there
they give me this stuff Christine's
there God bless her she when I you know
when I think about it when I hate her I
picture her trying to sleep with her
feet up on the wall in this little chair
trying to sleep next to me in the I'm in
the hospital bed yeah and then uh like
pressure was high you go in then you
have I got my surgery yeah I I had a bat
I I was so heavy it came out rough my
three fingers were numb my thumbs and
two fingers on both hands were numb yeah
they didn't know why my blood pressure
was through the roof yeah it was bad
like I felt like I was dying I thought I
was gonna die after my surgery
and
my wife came in and then she was a guy I
I gotta go and then she took my son home
and I'm like okay yeah she's like I'm
not saying this [ __ ] all tonight yeah
you'll be fine she left I was by myself
just puking oh no I'm so sad yeah my
wife did not call the neighbor didn't
get anybody to watch the kid she goes I
gotta go home Max has homework
this was in the daytime though yeah mine
was the middle of the night oh yeah yeah
okay and then uh so the next day the
part of the story really [ __ ] you up
part of the story up I apologize it's
all right I get it it's just you know
you you're saying how much you love dude
yeah the caring attentiveness of our
wives and then uh they get all the
levels down they're like yeah your
pressure's high you're not having a
heart attack you're almost at a stroke
here's this you're gonna have to do this
and then the next day they let me go and
then they go to take the IV out of me
and I guess the woman's new at it Blood
starts spraying all over the hospital
room takes it out just all over like
I've been stabbed like that and I go is
this supposed to and then they calm it
down buddy I got my when I they had my
IV in yeah the girl came in she blew my
vein out five times yeah she didn't know
what the [ __ ] no these people are dumb
my wife was there at that time that's
why I love my wife yeah she's like is
there somebody here that knows how to do
this I don't want you doing it to my
husband again so they went and they got
my doctor got his
whatever any serious yeah she came up
one shot
perfectly yeah some of these people are
real bad at their jobs I think that
I think it's a community college course
I don't know dude but it's like if you
don't know how to stick a needle and
stick a needle in a [ __ ] vein that's
the easiest thing to do to practice on a
cantaloupe or something unbelievable and
then so I had to now I'm on meds and I
had to you know they tell you different
things every time you go well the first
guys like don't eat red meat you can't
smoke anymore uh do this don't eat
before bed and I had like a not a reflux
thing but they had to give me this thing
for my uh What's this called here what's
down there yeah clavicle no the uh the
part of the throat the [ __ ] where the
[ __ ] hits the tip of the [ __ ] that's
right
it's uh this the happy spot the happy
spot the mouth G-spot [ __ ] priest
seminal fluid holder they they give me
all these mats that no red meat then I
go to the first cardiologist yeah
something like that and they get it's a
pill for that and then they give me uh
esophagus esophagus that's what it is
there's a pill for the esophagus and
anaprazole or something like that they
gave me and then uh I get up checked out
I go in doctor goes all right you have
heart disease you have blockages and so
he's like don't freak out yet I'm
freaking out we don't know how bad it is
is it hereditary yeah Dad has it the
whole family had it so it's like you got
to change everything so this guy goes
you do have heart disease there's
blockages so then I I have to go so then
everyone's like get a second opinion and
then you're like no he knows there's
blockages he's seen there's blockages
he's he's seen this blockages so I go
for a second opinion this guy's like a
big city doctor but lives in Jersey now
and uh he goes yeah you get blockages
here's the percentage go for the calcium
test they call it's not bad it's like
Point thirty percent whatever it is
they're like if you're over a hundred
that's real bad they're what am I moving
my microwave you keep doing this yeah
and so I turned I have heart disease and
then you they go if it's real bad you
got to get open heart surgery or bypass
and if it's not then you just [ __ ]
make the changes you have to make so I
get the 0.30 they're like you're good
just change your diet but then they
start telling you different things don't
eat don't eat dairy don't eat that you
can eat red meat but don't eat that then
the other doctor I go to he goes look
I'm a cigar smoker I love them take it
once in a while to just see my wife that
she's like
she wanted him to say you can't smoke
anymore so I I went with that that guy
he seemed like he knew what he was
talking about better than the first guy
but you smoke one one a day come on not
even I go some days without
I go a week without sometimes not too
nicotine gum if I'm around my wife I
don't smoke right I chew nicotine like a
[ __ ] I go on the road don't make
this the clip
yeah don't make this a clip why are you
out of your mind of course this is the
clip don't make this the clip this is
the clip don't make this the clip why
would we not make this a clip I just
talked to another comic that's getting
divorced and now you're gonna make me go
through this yeah you think you're gonna
get divorced no she's not gonna leave
you I would not uh yeah do not smoke
around my wife at all but then she'll
think I have [ __ ]
yeah you can't it's two Comics two
cigars but Joe this is here you can say
hi but often you can't be on it hi
I want to smell good I'll sit over there
yeah do that get us get a chair I don't
know where there is one there's one
inside they got the chair inside in the
green room they have extra chairs or ask
somebody to eat yellow shirt will get
you one
okay yeah it's hot
in the box right here um
yeah the Joe list is here you can't he
can't be it's too Comics not three
Comics two cigarettes it's too Congress
even if he's got a cigar you can be here
but you can't be on camera
the sun is brutal it's on my face you
can't tell but it's I'm smoking a Joe
Rogan Experience
why don't we we mean uh me and uh Ari
actually went to the foundation farms in
Connecticut
the podcast sits out uh before Oh great
show that's where Joe cigars come from
into the tobacco fields we did the
podcast yeah and he gave us you can't
buy these cigars but you can buy these
These are amazing I mean
yeah these uh ladies you 1922 yeah
Rhymes it's going uh tell them where you
got that from Bobby
Joe gave me this but I gave you a Rogan
are you getting a Rogan for that yeah I
switched it up how do you like the Rogan
have you done an episode with the Rogue
I just told you me and Ari went to the
fields yeah but I like took from that
was he tried to pee in the fields and
you said don't pee there he pissed in
defense he's a Savage people people give
their lives to this art of making cigars
and this wiry Jew thinks he can go
[ __ ] urinate in the middle of a
[ __ ] tobacco field yeah somebody I
love him so so so but here's the thing
though now that you found out you have
heart disease it's in your family
when I when Colin had a heart attack
all's I was thinking like I'm gonna die
I went and got all my I'm like I'm gonna
have a heart attack because you guys
considered yourselves family so you
thought you got it for me I was no I was
overweight yeah I smoked cigars everyone
thought you weren't the guy that
everyone said I heard you say like
everyone's talking behind your back
thinking you're gonna die I don't think
a lot of people said that the people
that told me they were saying that
they're full of [ __ ] Ari said yeah dude
we were worried about you okay Joe were
you worried about me uh yeah I worry
about you no I'm not in general Joe I'm
when I was fat when I was 350. uh yeah I
mean you know eventually you get the
bill for that you know yeah you owe us
uh your life
I was worried it was worried yeah I
guess okay we're back sorry technically
my phone actually overheated
which is nuts so this has been a I mean
we've been really working for this
podcast yeah we're working
we're not messing around it's not bad it
beats digging ditches oh yeah look at
you Mr positive after you had a heart
attack yeah it wasn't a heart attack
that's Strokes there's a lot of false
information out there about it somebody
uh somebody I like to not name names of
the old place I used to work at one of
them was like he's in the hospital
because the blood clots from the vaccine
he took the Johnson and Johnson vaccine
and he's got blood clots really it's
[ __ ] hereditary heart disease you
[ __ ] dummy oh man people love to do
[ __ ] to it they really do love to spread
rumors and people believe it people
believe everything well when I saw you
in the why is it though anytime we're in
the hospital you know if my wife went to
the hospital the last thing she'd do is
take a picture and put it on social
media yeah but us we'd love to hey guys
because we don't want all these people
to think we're dying but then they get
worried that we're dying and then we're
like nah it's not a big deal but I just
had to share it because I was scared I
was gonna die I did think there was when
I was there I was like you know what I
had a good enough life I could is the
only thing that kept me not shutting my
eyes and dying me my daughter oh sorry
and yeah the possibility of doing this
one day I mean if I have two comments
two 45-minute podcast over three and a
half hours I know dude it's taken us so
long overheated the mics die but we're
back in we're back yeah I really thought
I had a moment where I was like I could
go because I was almost 50 and I was
like I've had a good life yeah it's
weird when I got my surgery that night I
had to kind of come to terms with like
when I was my heart my blood pressure
was skyrocketed and I couldn't feel my
fingers I was like [ __ ]
I mean this might be I might not wake up
yeah and that's why I didn't tell
anybody about it no I didn't do anything
I didn't tell anybody about it because
I don't want to oh you're gonna go in
and get this good for you and then I die
and then I ruin it for every fat dude
fat girl who's getting that surgery
they'd be like I'm not doing that
there's other fat people that need to
take
what you've done and do it there's
people here this weekend that are Comics
well you walk in a tightrope you gotta
it's not for everybody because there are
people there's two of them and I'll name
the names they need it we should do a
good one who Zach needs to do something
I want Jack to do it I think Zach I love
Zach and Zach I talked to him he I think
he's thinking about it yeah he needs to
do something yeah but you the problem is
people think you get it and then it's it
that's it look Ralphie May had several
of them he had lap band he had the band
nice the band is nice what did you know
did you get I got the uh I got the
gastric sleeve oh the sleeve sleeve is
better sleeves better than the band the
band you could break through what do you
mean you eat too much and it breaks pops
yeah the brand ban Ralphie threw two
bands come on swear to God what just to
get one sandwich in I don't know dude he
ate two bands that's not good no the
sleeve they make it not eat the same as
you eat is what he's saying the thing
with the sleeve if I eat too much I
throw up there's like a oh that's good
yeah I'll be thrown up yeah like a
balloon I've got a three three or four
times because you forget you're just
eating and you forget ah and then all of
a sudden you're like what put it it's so
embarrassing you do it you know you're
going to throw up though you go your
mouth starts watering yeah that's how
you know and you're like oh God and you
got to go to the bathroom and it comes
up it's like mostly flemmy yeah it's
just I think it pushes out the stuff in
your baby stomach what's wrong well that
this young lady and I just connected
because we both went like this oh
is she behind me yeah
wow so what's your I don't know if you
go buy calories or what but what's your
like tap out like say can you eat steak
still I can have filet like not I can
have steak you don't need a big old fat
rib eye I used to go get a rib eye
that's what I used to get rib eye and I
would start with the fat yeah and like
the tastiest part oh God love the fat
yeah
oh yeah you I feel full like you have to
see the thing is you got fat memory so
like you're fat I'm not fat memory you
I'll eat and it shuts down the
how full you are I don't even think of
that now I eat slow and I know I'm full
if I take another bite I'm gonna it
hurts so it's actually it's like a a
governor yeah so it's great that happens
to me if I go to a steakhouse and I eat
a full meal like truffle mac and cheese
a steak fries and then I get the dessert
and I start eating the dessert and then
you're like oh that hurts but it tastes
so good you literally make it you're
making your stomach bigger yeah you're
stretching it out like a wet shirt yeah
no pain no gain no pain no game baby
stretch you gotta [ __ ] stretch that
belly out like your shirts oh boy I like
a flourless chocolate cake what do you
miss the most what can you not eat or
you can eat everything I can have
anything I can have anything right now
what's your favorite [ __ ] I love [ __ ]
yeah I miss [ __ ] me too yeah I haven't
eaten my I mean we don't we get the Kid
we got a small house so there's no
really time and she goes to bed at like
9 30. yeah so there's no I was thinking
about that the other day is like
you know when you first hooked up with a
girl
that was like
you know one of the sexiest moments is
when you make that decision
I'm going downtown
because it's a big decision yeah because
you don't know what's down there no you
don't know what every vagina is
different yeah some big lady is little
labias big [ __ ] little click can't find
the [ __ ] yeah you know you get down
there and you got to go to work it's not
like a penis is easy and you see a nice
remember you see a nice vagina be like
oh this one's good ah I'm gonna keep
this one for a couple months yeah no no
like you you see me it's like this is
nice that's my wife's best quality is
she doesn't stink yeah mine too that's
what I tell her I go the best thing
about you you don't stink yeah mine mine
doesn't because no one touches it
my wife could wear yoga pants for two
days it's still fine yeah my wife's
tighter than a two-year-old
yeah
I missed that you ever get a bad one a
bit oh yeah had a lot of bad ones yeah a
lot of them a lot of them yeah I've only
had a couple bad ones yeah could you
imagine if you were to ever yeah ever
where to go all right I'm gonna cheat on
my wife and then he bring some filthy
skank um back to your hotel just box
stinking up your hotel room and then you
do it anyways and then she leaves but
then it's still on your upper lip for a
couple days and You Gotta Throw your
pants out yeah
dry humping it yeah my underwear off
like just just all jizz in it yeah looks
like I did Pottery inside my pants
yeah but it's good we're healthy now we
feel better we feel better I feel good
man what did your doctor say about the
sticks
no I'll do what oh my daughter you know
where I met my doctor
Cigar Lounge Cigar Lounge yeah I didn't
know it was a doctor we were talking one
day maybe he's not he is he's great yeah
our pen he's awesome he uh yeah we would
smoke sticks and then one day I found as
a doctor then one day I found out he uh
this is his specialty is gastro [ __ ] and
he told me about the surgery like three
years ago and I he but he he he's like
if you're gonna do it you gotta it takes
a lot and I you're gonna do he did my
belly button hernia yeah I had one of
those awful little look like like Total
Recall had little like the little guy
Cupquake yeah coming out of my belly
button which is basically a hole in your
intestines and it was in your stomach
and your intestines are coming through
your belly button yeah that's not good
dude it was embarrassing you have a lot
of gross stuff about you
you know there's a lot of really gross
things about like you're a really nice
guy and very giving but on the inside
there's a lot of really gross things
about well I got the belly button hernia
fixed yeah thank God and I went I went
in for that and that's when we really
started talking about and I had a
esophageal hernia up here and he's like
when I go in to do your surgery I'll fix
that too so he fixed that
so when I went into the hospital I told
people I was getting my esophageal
hernia fixed which I did so it wasn't
lying yeah but
it's good that you didn't want people to
worry that's a good thing I didn't want
people to wear anything not a lie it's
just like a little kind of you know a
misdirection you want your lighter yeah
one good thing about the my fathers is
they burn through and through good yeah
you know I I very rarely have I've ever
had to this sucks though you're gonna
take the bands off look how pretty that
is yeah they're very pretty bad so
pretty but I very rarely have to relight
on my father yeah you light it up and
you're finishing it yeah I mean good
sticks it's a great stick
um
so
how are you um how are you feeling now
you good I feel good I exercise like I
always was exercising but I started kind
of intermittent fasting now so I'll go
you know uh 16 hours without eating wow
and it's taken a little bit and all it
means is I stop eating six at night and
I don't eat till 10 in the morning I
feel so good when I eat dinner around
five six seven and I don't eat until
like 11 the next day yeah that's exactly
I don't know why yeah I don't know why
that is so you feel so strong supposed
to eat before bed I used to eat a box of
sugar cereal before I'd sit down with
count chocula yeah eat a box good and I
was like this isn't bad did you drink
the milk no I wouldn't drink this you
didn't drink the milk it's not because I
was using skim milk so it's yeah but
it's chocolate yeah but it's just like a
chocolate puddle it's not that good
I stopped eating and now I'm gonna do
I'm doing a thing I'm only eating pizza
for eight weeks why I got a new sponsor
they make this uh this carbohydrate free
pizza what it's made of chicken breast
the crust [ __ ] you yeah I'm gonna I'll
get you some no way to say the name yeah
because the deal's not Inked are you
kidding me I'm not kidding you you're
gonna love this [ __ ] I want them to be
my sponsor or come on your show we'll
talk about it yeah yeah dude chicken
skin no chicken breast chicken breast
they make into a crust I'm telling you
they're [ __ ] sausage pizza it's like
you're in Chicago really that good no
carbs it's not no carbs you sure guess
how that pizza has 57 grams of protein
and by the way you can't even eat the
whole one because it's so you you split
it up a pizza is two meals wow it's like
eating chicken breasts all day sodium's
a little high you gotta watch this so
you gotta watch the sodium sodium like
that will swell me the [ __ ] up yeah I
gotta watch everything now but I feel
once you get that kick start I love I
went to the gym every day in skank Fest
yeah every morning I went to the gym I
just want to go to the gym I took
yesterday off I love it I love and I
don't work out crazy I work out I go on
YouTube I get some shredded black guy
that does dumbbell workouts yeah and I
just do what he does and then I do uh I
was running this I ran for the first
time on a treadmill
your shins hurt no I can't I got those
hookers you gotta get the Hoka what are
those it's a shoe it's a running shoe
it's [ __ ] great all right
um
yeah I feel great I'm glad though now
let me ask you a question so you you you
now that you've left the show with all
the stuff the stress behind yeah is is
it is all your stress gone how much how
much percentage-wise stress did you
relieve by changing everything 80 by by
leaving 80 80 and now I'm more present
I'm a better dad I'm a better husband uh
you know that [ __ ] I I talk to you and I
talk to other people and you're like you
just move ahead don't look back which is
the Temptation people think if they look
look back it's gonna help and that's
where all the drama and all the [ __ ]
comes from so I didn't and I'm way
happier and I knew I was taking a
financial hit by leaving
and then uh you know I don't know I
figured I'd uh I just make it up so I go
on the road more and that's it you're on
the road more and make the money up I
said I'd never have to like these but I
gotta light it I know it was really bad
I was hoping you were gonna get it there
so that you wouldn't have to prove
yourself wrong well I taught I was I was
talking for a while yeah so anyways
80 well that's a trick you know you
think you know when you do something
like that drastic
it's a drastic move it's a ballsy move
when you're supporting a family
to leave a job
and just say this is the right thing to
do
it's not it's not you can keep doing the
wrong thing those people are miserable
and then it also teaches you money's not
everything you know what I mean
I'm gassing the cigar out yeah look at
that
that's what that's called the [ __ ] at
the end Adam that's right you light it
you let it on fire and then blow it out
that way very lightly not too hard and
it gasses it up watches
that's like brand new if you don't it's
gonna taste like [ __ ] it's gonna taste
that [ __ ] it tastes fantastic right now
no yeah it's true like
I remember you know because the fans
that didn't come with you weren't your
fans
they don't they didn't really give a
[ __ ] about you yeah and the ones that
came were the ones that liked you yeah
enough to come with you three were the
best guys
was it not was it not I'm telling you
there was a big we cleaned house a lot
of people Anthony is a very loyal fan
base that went with Anthony
so those are the type of fans that you
know they're doing their [ __ ] ride or
die with him yeah they are right I mean
you gotta respect that yeah you got to
respect the ride or die and they want to
make it about everything except what it
is you know it's like oh you're a [ __ ]
now because you're you're a seller and
it's like no I just don't do you got it
you gotta you don't do it you don't do a
thing it's not gonna last forever even
if it's a good thing you don't do it my
Fern had a great thing he's gone too
long Stern could have checked out
Opie and Anthony yeah you know now it's
Jim and Sam yeah right sometimes it's uh
Sam and Feeney yeah sometimes it's Sam
and Bobby yeah but it's uh yeah
everything comes to an end yeah and
that's the sad part about a lot of this
stuff but that's also the beautiful
thing about why we got into this is that
so our lives aren't always the same this
is right you know you Embrace uncertain
it's a tough decision because you know
look when I decided to have a kid and
move up to the suburbs I was like [ __ ]
I'm not going to be in the city anymore
I'm gonna lose my Edge I didn't I just I
found something else yeah to talk about
some other angle to talk about you don't
lose who you are no you don't you just
you're you're in another element now and
it makes you grow it does make you grow
and I'm glad you did it yeah me too I'm
glad you did it because you're uh
the last couple times I've seen you have
been such a great mood you know yeah
your Energy's better because that time
in Chicago dude yeah it was uh you were
looking at it you were looking into the
[ __ ] gray yeah you were like
somewhere else yeah you're like what am
I doing I'm just doing this for money
I'm not happy and uh yeah I'm glad I was
able to make that move well
so let's rate this cigar let's get into
this
we're at the end
we gotta go do some shows yeah live here
at skank Fest Joe list is with us off
camera because it's two Comics two
cigars yeah he's smoking a Rogan and I'm
and I'm ugly
oh
you're not ugly you're you're cute you
got to put some sunblock on your [ __ ]
head is red yeah there's a little red
you were in the sun dude yeah you got a
little bit of sun yeah you gotta Vegas
your hair looks great
that's I would kill for a head of hair
like that right now get your hand out of
it it's two Comics two cigars I'm
telling you thank you because Bobby was
saying I have bad hair yeah oh I'd be
like a camera right after almost lead
this is no product this is just went
showered and went to bed they can't see
but it's fantastic leave Aaron Bird
that's my hashtag hashtag hashtag
believe all burgs
um so I I mean
my father my favorite cigar the judge
I'm gonna tell you this it was my
favorite cigar lebbies you what we're
smoking today is my favorite song are
you really more so than the judge
because I think the Judge the one I like
is too big of a ring gauge for my mouth
sometimes and I'll be like oh I get a
little [ __ ] mouth I'm talking about
hang on here we go type type two it's
called type 2 miles also labajou is my
favorite cigar in fact I travel with one
3 000 miles and saved it for the last
day and Bob took it
wait two Comics we have to smoke the
same cigar but we yeah we got a great uh
we got a great episode of this I I'm
gonna give this a go wait wait I gotta
tell you how to rate it oh okay none one
five or a box huh none I would smoke
none of these I get one I get five of
these I do five yeah well I'm gonna get
I get a box of these okay
a box Libby shoe 1922 a box I I would
say
I'm tempted to save
I'm joking in it I'm tempted to say five
not because it's a I love this cigar
it's a great cigar
but I'm also gonna say this you've got a
massive wholesale size humidor in your
house you are more a man of variety you
like to switch it up
I have a box of Libby's use I can go
Libby Zoo
for the whole box
I would I would get I would get a box of
Judge yeah
I think I would do five of these there
you go I would do five here's why I love
them
this cigar is epic
it's been amazing all the way through
but I like a bigger cigar ette I like a
bigger cigar I like a I gotta I gotta I
got a regular sized mouth yeah
I like a bigger ring gauge some people
would say you got a big mouth
who says that a lot of people
[Music]
I live with like a big mouth part of
your charm it's part of my charm I would
say I would take five of these epic
cigar great cigar if you're going to a
wedding get a box bring it everybody
smokes it if you you're anywhere any
humidor anywhere any cigar lounge you
see one of these on the shelf 1922. that
beats you get one of these not easy to
find it's a perfect hour or so cigar
especially good if a friend brings one
it's a special good if it belongs to a
friend that you took it from yeah I gave
you a Rogan
really that's kind of like a native
trade we took the real good land and
gave him a blanket you want to take a
puff oh
I wet it I wet it I wet it I suck on it
that's how you smoke yeah you smoke you
just got like you you were blowing a Kid
Joe smokes much better now when I first
met Joe he would smoke very fast
and now Joe's very relaxed and now he
puts in his mouth and I suck on it I
like a wet a wet end yeah I don't want
anybody thinking they could take a puff
off of it no no you have women come up
and ask that mine's not bad you're
driving women go can I take a drag of
that again no are people on the street
in New York can I get a hit of that no
and I laugh at them if you don't do that
you don't ask somebody I've done it
there's been a couple girls wait can I
try a couple real hot girls I let uh
Jordan uh Jordan uh Jensen yeah I let
her take a puff on mine Jordan Ferber
Jordan Peterson
I let that dude take a puff
but uh yeah yeah but you know she right
at the beginning yeah but halfway
through and you're like this get the
fight you don't do it you don't ask all
right taste your [ __ ] gastric sleeve
how far down it is now no more acid
reflux too it's all gone good all gone
tonight what are you eating for dinner
I'm probably gonna do it on eat with me
oh yeah yeah right I don't eat yeah you
don't eat with me well all right we're
gonna finish this up we're at skank Fest
live two Comics two cigars I'm here with
Aaron Berg the great Aaron Burke your
new podcast is what Berg's base on gas
digital uh wherever you get podcasts as
well it's on YouTube and all those
things and what else you got going on
got a special coming out the specials
already out where is it it's uh nowhere
I buried it why you never see it because
someone told me to take it down because
uh they're gonna try and uh put some of
the material somewhere else
so it's right there's an album out I got
five albums out you can get them all my
live tour dates are on aaronberg.com I'm
touring with Lewis offend everyone that
goes until yeah what is up with that toy
that toy is going good really fun let's
tell Louis add me on it let's do
theaters that'll be great and we'll do
that let's do theaters yeah I'll do that
it's really [ __ ] fun let's go offend
everybody we offend that because no one
gets offended you know here because you
know why you you it's in the title like
you you psychologically tell them that
crazy [ __ ] up edgy comedy is about to
happen so you release that part of them
where they're you know they're coming in
expecting some
clean comedy show they see on TV yeah
they know they're going to be [ __ ]
offended yeah they know they're going to
hear crazy [ __ ] so they're okay with it
and it's not that bad it's not that bad
no you're not no and Lee Lewis isn't
very funny both of you guys very [ __ ]
funny yeah I I would love to be part of
that and and if you see that show you
got to go see it yeah people love it so
goddamn funny that's great all right
well thank you for coming on thanks for
having me and make sure you check out
killbox louisck.com yeah it's a [ __ ]
great special Bobby's hilarious you
gotta go get it yeah Louis ck.com if
you're watching this go drop the 10
bucks easy as pie you can own it you can
download it you can stream it whatever
you want on any device uh the great
Louis CK directed It produced it I'm
very proud of it so go get it killbox
louisck.com we'll see you guys next time
on two Comics two cigars two cigars and
thank you my father and our boy Steve
yeah Steve who always hooks us up
tri-state area that's right so check it
out oh we got Mike Cannon and Feeney
showed up yeah uh what's up guys and uh
we'll see you guys next time take care
take care bye-bye skag Fest out